and by the way the president maybe some
say his own best spokesperson but should
the office of the press secretary live
vacant well what does he actually need
who better to ask than two men who have
held that difficult post Ari Fleischer
is a Fox News contributor and was press
secretary for President George W Bush
and Sean Spicer was president Trump's
first press secretary and is now a
senior advisor and spokesman for America
first action all right guys ari let's
start with you
now press briefings are kind of up in
the air for the time being and my
question is does he need more of a
political operator in the position of
press secretary
then perhaps previous presidents
especially ahead of the 2020 election I
do think and obviously I'm a little
traditional that it can be very
advantageous for the president but it
depends on who the person is and how
tolerant the president is look I think
if he has what I would call a happy
warrior somebody who loves the President
believes and the president will fight
with the president but does it with a
humorous touch not a truculent touch he
can turn that room to his advantage the
bias of the press is so overwhelming it
actually becomes an opportunity for a
press secretary who lets the press hoist
themselves on their own petard if they
do the job right well Sean you stood
there day after day dealing with this
and you know people say president
Trump's a really tough boss he's heart
you can't please I'm like we've all
heard that it's been said about all
their people but you stood there and you
dealt with this press day in and day out
does he need a press secretary or is it
kind of a superfluous position at this
point first let me just make sure I wish
the president a happy birthday today but
I do think I do think he needs one and
I'll tell you why the job an already
knows this better than anybody he did it
with class and and just a level of
integrity that was became a mentor to me
but the job that people see on
television about 5% of what happens
there is a facilitation of access and
interviews to other government officials
to information the
coming in and out of the White House
whether it's personnel events or
policies so the press office is very
very busy all day long
facilitating these other things
logistical movements of the press pool
the rest of press arrangements for
events and and also speaking on a whole
host of other issues regarding the White
House that aren't always exactly just
the President himself so of course there
needs to be a press secretary in a press
office I would differ with Ari a little
bit that because this president has been
so much more accessible and engages so
much more
I think the briefings server utility
they should be they should occur but
maybe not on a daily basis Sarah and the
rest of the press team should continue
with whoever fills this role to engage
in the press but if you saw with Sarah
she's out there on the driveway all the
time on camera talking to the press they
just want it in a briefing room where
they can make it about them when the
cameras just focused on her and it's not
about them they don't like it as much
because it doesn't work well for their
cable contracts and your YouTube views
and things like that I think that's an
excellent point it's it's Showtime and
they want to be you know they want to be
the lead in the show for their network
or their audience and I guess that's
human nature but Ari I want to get your
thoughts on what cNN's Jim Acosta had to
say about Sarah Sanders watch I think
she really acted as another employee of
the Trump Organization we should not be
in the business of having the United
States government referring to
journalists or any segment of the
population as the enemy of the people I
think she fell short of her duty to the
American people and it's going to be
part of her legacy and I think it's a
cautionary tale for people who go to
work for this president
one of the most sickening ly biased
individuals in the u.s. press corps
right now Jim Acosta so I'm going to
give him too much credence but is that
the press secretary serving at the
pleasure of the President I mean serving
the president she's not serving CNN or
or Fox or anyone else she's serving the
president his agenda and obviously wants
to get it right she doesn't want to get
the issues wrong or
come on well two things number one Jim
Acosta just wrote a book which I won't
buy but I heard somebody say that he
wrote in there that in this day and age
it's too important to be neutral you
have to be against President Bush that's
a president Trump that's a paraphrase so
that tells you where Jim Acosta is but
the press Secretary's job is to first
and foremost represent the president you
are their spokesperson your job is to
take the podium and speak on behalf of
the President to represent issues the
way the president would represent issues
it has nothing to do with your own
demeanor your own style well your own
viewpoints on issues your job is to do
it the way the president wants now
ideally you also do it to help the press
chord get the stories and get it covered
and do it accurately and all of that is
what makes it a very tricky job where
you walk a tightrope between two people
to organization well one person the
president and the press corps but make
no mistake your first boss is the prey
on it and Shawn real quick would you've
given George Stephanopoulos two days of
access to the president yes or no would
you have Shawn I think whenever
President Trump can get in front of
people in show whether it's a journalist
or a group why he's doing something in
his own words it's a good thing and so I
always default to the fact that it's
better for him to be out there showing
and talking to folks about his policy I
don't know that I would hanging out the
Oval Office hole and standing over the
President of the United States I don't
like that at all you can go ahead all
right they shouldn't let him back in no
he's a little too comfortable in the
Oval Office Stephanopoulos I will say
this I will say that that I think that
the president there are a lot of
additional outlets that have been very
fair that deserve an opportunity or
would do a lot better job of presenting
the president the policies in this
administration yeah bingo
all right panel thanks so much